[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend schön dass Sie
dabei sind wie auch Norbert König für
den Sport guten Abend die Lage im
nahenosten spitzt sich
zu Krieg in Israel die Armee riegelt den
Gazastreifen komplett ab es gibt aber
weiterhin Raketenangriffe der Hamas
sowie Gefechte auf israelischem
Gebiet
wahlnachlese die ampelparteien
analysieren die Niederlagen in Bayern
und Hessen während die AFD ihre Erfolge
dort
feiert kennenlernen in Übersee
neubundestrainer nagelsmann und sein
Team treten die umstrittene USA Reise
an Israel rüstet sich für einen langen
Krieg 300.000 Reservisten sind
einberufen so viele wie noch nie seit
Samstag wurden bei der Terrorattacke der
Hamas auf israelischer Seite 800
Menschen getötet 2600 verletzt die Hamas
operiert aus dem Gazastreifen und den
will die israelische Regierung jetzt
komplett abriegeln der Streifen ist
gerade mal 6 bis 12 km breit und 40 km
lang und dicht besiegelt mehr als 2
Millionen Menschen leben dort sie
bekommen keinen Strom mehr kein er keine
Lebensmittel mindestens 560 Menschen
starben nach palästinensischen Angaben
bislang bei den israelischen
Gegenschlägen hier doch die Hamas
schickt weiter Raketen aus Gaza nach
Israel lck
walpot auch zwei Tage nach dem Beginn
der Kämpfe starten heute tödliche
hamasraketen aus Gaza in Richtung Israel
in der Stadt Aschkelon wurde ein
Wohnhaus getroffen zwei Menschen schwer
verletzt Israels Armee antwortet vorerst
aus der der Luft mehr als 500 Ziele der
hamasse im Gazastreifen sein getroffen
und zerstört worden so dass Militär
hunderte hamasterroristen ausgeschaltet
für eine mögliche Bodenoffensive hat
Israel starke Truppenverbände
zusammengezogen der gazaastifen so der
Verteidigungsminister werde komplett
abgeriegelt keinen Strom mehr keine
Lebensmittel kein Wasser kein Brennstoff
wir kämpfen hier gegen Menschen die sich
wie Tiere benehmen
der Schock in Israel sitzt tief in
großer Zahl hatten Hamas Terroristen am
Samstag die schwer gesicherten
Grenzsperren überwunden hatten Jagd auf
israelische Zivilisten gemacht sie
drangen in Häuser ein töteten hunderte
verschleppten mehr als 130 Menschen
darunter Frauen und Kinder in den Gasa
Streifen diese Familie mit deutschem
Pass bangt um ihre Angehörigen deren
Schicksal völlig
ungewiss vor allem wissen wie es Ihnen
geht ob sie irgendwie sicher sind
natürlich möchte ich meine Mutter
Wiedersehen meine Schwester meine Neffen
den Freund meiner Mutter die ganze
Familie bitte wenn irgendjemand uns
helfen kann
bitte
please besonders blutig der Überfall der
schwer beewwaffneten Hamas Terroristen
auf ein Open Air Konzert nah der Grenze
die entsetzten Besucher Rennen um ihr
Leben gilioskovt konnte
entkommen
sie sind von Baum zu Baum gegangen und
haben geschossen überall von zwei Seiten
ich habe Leute um mich herum sterben sie
überall um mich herum sah verschanzte
sich in einem Schutzbunker er überleebte
schwer
verletzt sie warfen eine Handgranate in
dem Bunker die Schreie waren entsetzlich
dann schossen sie wahos in die
Grupp viele Orts in Israel gingen
Menschen heute zur Blutspende Versorgung
der Verwundeten sicherzustellen das Land
bereitet sich auf einen langen schweren
Konflikt
vor Michael bwerunge ist wieder in der
Nähe des Gazastreifens unterwegs in
Aschkelon Michael Israel wird weiter
beschossen und bombardiert seinerseits
sowohl den Gasastreifen als auch Ziele
im Libanon wohin entwickelt sich
das ich fürchte die Zeichen stehen auf
Sturm und die Raketen die gerade auf
Aschkelon und andere Städte in Israel
abgefeuert werden und die Bomben die auf
Gaza fallen sind nur der Auftag zu einer
weitaus größeren Schlacht die Regierung
hat kein Zweifel daran gelassen dass ihr
Ziel ist die komplette Hamas Führung und
die kompletten hamaskämpfer und in
hijjad zu beseitigen das ist nur
militärisch mit einer Bodenoffensive
möglich und alle Zeichen deuten darum
dass die gerade intensiv vorbereitet ist
wir selbst haben hier große
Panzerkolonnen im Süden auch
aufmschieren sehen ganze Ortschaft die
ganzen Siedlungen die jetzt von der
Hamas eingenommen waren sind danach
evakuiert worden weil es eine Kampfzone
werden könnte das gleiche findet im
Norden statt und premier no hat gesagt
die Antwort Israels die wird so
ausfallen dass der Nahe Osten danach ein
anderer sein wird was ist mit den
Geiseln etwa 150 sollen in der Gewalt
der Terroristen
sein
ich fürchte auch das ist ein Drama was
Israel und die Welt weiter beschäftigen
wird sie sind zunächst einmal ein
Druckmittel im Psychoterror der Hamas um
die Angehörigen die hier in Israel
zittern sich in zahlreichen Blocks
äußern zusammenschließen aber
letztendlich völlig ohnmächtig sind
weiter zu verunsichern und sie sind
natürlich ein faustfand für eine
mögliche Bodenoffensive möglicherweise
menschliche Schutzschilde schon jetzt
werden sie zur Verunsicherung genutzt es
gab heute eine Nachricht von einem
hamassprecher israelische Bomben hätten
bereits vier israelische geisenn getötet
ob das stimmt oder nicht kann jemand
nachvollziehen aber das ist Teil dieses
psychoterrorspiels was gerade hier
abläuft danke schön für diese
Einschätzung live aus Israel Michael
Bunge war
das wer kann verhindern dass dieser
Konflikt weiter eskaliert Ägypten könnte
eine Vermittlerrolle einnehmen die arab
Liga kündigte ein Sondertreffen am
Mittwoch an ihr Generalsekretär geid hat
sich heute in Moskau mit dem
ausrussischen Außenminister lavrov
getroffen beide forderten ein Ende der
Kämpfe geid sagte aber die Gewalt werde
weitergehen solange die Palästina Frage
ungelöst
bleibe die EU-Kommission hat sämtliche
Zahlungen an die Palästinenser vorerst
gestoppt an die Hamas oder andere
Terrororganisationen sei so eso weder
direkt noch indirekt Geld geflossen so
die EU bisher hat sie vor allem sozial
und Gesundheitsprojekte finanziert
außerdem politische und wirtschaftliche
Initiativen auch entwicklungsministerin
Schulze setzt die Finanzierung von
Projekten in den Palästinensergebieten
aus Patrizia Wiedemeier über weitere
Reaktionen in
Deutschland die Solidarität mit Israel
hält an heute abend gehen sie wieder auf
die Straße in ST wie hier in Hannover
das schockt einfach friert so sehr da
konnte ich auch nicht so richtig zu
Hause bleiben in einem demokratischen
Staat wo wir das Recht haben zu
demonstrieren auch so eine Art
moralische Verpflichtung haben uns gegen
diejenigen zu Werren die diese Welt
einfach nicht in Frieden leben lassen
wollen ich könte mir vorstellen dass da
ein Flächenbrand gibt im Nahen Osten und
das wä natürlich sehr sehr gefährlich
deutschland stehe fest an der Seite
Israels ist immer wieder zu hören von
den Bürgern von den Politikern vom
Bundespräsidenten Zeit steht Deutschland
fest an der Seite Israels darauf kann
sich das israelische Volk und darauf
können sich auch Jüdin und Juden in
Deutschland verlassen gleichzeitig
betonte er dass das jüdische Leben in
Deutschland geschützt werden müsse wer
die brutalen Attacken auf Israel feiere
sowie es am Wochenende im Berliner
Stadtteil Neuköln geschah trte die
Menschenwürde und die deutsche
Verfassung mit
Füßen solches Verhalten
entsetzt
mich es wiedelt mich an
entwicklungsministerin Schulze kündigte
an Zahlungen für Projekte in den
palästinensischen Gebieten vorerst
auszusetzen zugesagt waren etwa 250
Millionen für dieses Jahr auch die EU
legt Gelder auf
Eis wir wollen das mit Israel besprechen
wie unsere Entwicklungsprojekte dem
Frieden in der Region und der Sicherheit
Israels am Besten dienen können und das
ist auch ein ein Ausdruck unserer
unverbrüchlichen solid
mit Israel für den Zentralrat der Juden
ist das Einfrieren der Gelder nur ein
erster
Schritt es geht darum
überhaupt Organisation mit Verbindungen
zu palästinensischen
Terrororganisationen die in Deutschland
aktiv sind ihre Aktivitäten zu
untersagen die Lage in Israel sie ist
auch Thema bei den deutsch-fanzösischen
Regierungskonsultationen in Hamburg die
Sicherheit Israels sei deutsche
staatsron betont der Kanzler erneut der
Terror wird nicht gewinnen der Hass wird
nicht siegen die Gewalt wird nicht
triumphieren die Bekämpfung des
Terrorismus ist eine gemeinsame Aufgabe
für uns gemeinsam mit Israel und unseren
internationalen Partnern es gibt keine
Rechtfertigung keine Erklärung
dafür am Abend wollen Scholz und macron
damit dem amerikanischen Präsidenten und
dem britischen Premier telefonieren es
ist der zweite Krieg mit dem Sie
innerhalb kürzester Zeit konfrontiert
werden zur dramatischen Lage im
nahenosten senden wir auch heute ein
Spezial gleich nach dieser Sendung und
über alle Entwicklung halten wir Sie
auch in der heute App auf dem
Laufenden es ist unsere Pflicht
Antisemitismus hart zu bekämpfen mahnt
Kanzler Scholz heute anlass ist der
vierte jahrestag des rechtsextremen
Anschlags auf die Synagoge in Halle dort
legten Bürgerinnen und Bürger sowie
Politiker krenze und Blumen nieder in
der Stadt läuteten die Glocken vor vier
Jahren hatte ein Attentäter am jüdischen
Feiertag jomkipur vergeblich versucht in
die Synagoge einzudringen anschließend
erschoss er zwei
Menschen jetzt zur wahlnachlese am Tag
nach den Landtagswahlen schauen wir auf
die vorläufigen amtlichen Endergebnisse
zuerst Bayern da erreicht die CSU
37% die Grünen 14 4 die Freien Wähler
15,8 die AFD wird drittstärkste Kraft
die SPD bleibt einstellig die FDP fliegt
aus dem Landtag Wahlsieger in Hessen ist
die CDU mit
34,6% auch hier verlieren Grüne und SPD
deutlich die AFD erreicht mit
18,4% platz2 die FDP schafft es gerade
noch in den Landtag linke und Freie
Wähler nicht eine Klatsche für die im
Bund Regierenden ampelpartner wie sie
damit umgehen zeigt Andreas
Huppert Blumen und eine Umarmung
schwacher Trost für die wahlverliererin
vom Parteichef vom Kanzler gibt's für
Nancy Feser nur einen Handschlag die
bundesinnenministerin hat als SPD
Spitzenkandidatin das historisch
schlechteste Ergebnis für die Genossen
in Hessen eingefahren der Grund für die
Wahlschlappe auch in Bayern den glaubt
die SPD gefunden zu haben das
Erscheinungsbild der ampelregierung in
Berlin dass die Menschen keinen Streit
Wünschen in der Regierung sondern dass
die Orientierung und dass die Sicherheit
sich wünschen dass sie antworten
wünschen auf die wirklich wichtigen
bedeutsamen und komplexen
Herausforderungen denen wir uns
gegenüber sehen all das hat die Ampel
offenbar vermissen lassen so sieht auch
die FDP für ihre Talfahrt und die
geringe Wählergunst vor allem
bundespolitische Gründe wo entsprechen
wir als Regierungskoalition in Berlin
nicht den Erwartungen der BGer und
Bürger insbesondere bei den Fragen die
ja wahlentscheidend in Hessen und Bayern
war das ist der Auftrag an uns und für
die Grünen ist klar was genau das für
Fragen sind die den Menschen unter den
Nägeln brennen allen voran das Thema
Migration bei denen die Bundesregierung
bislang nur unzureichend erklärt hat wie
sie diese anpacken
will wir haben eine Verunsicherung in
dieser Gesellschaft die uns ichtet dass
wir in den Mittelpunkt schieben die
wirtschaftliche Lage die Inflation die
Situation in der Ukraine die
Unterstützung die es dort braucht und
wir erleben eine insgesamt aufgeheizte
Stimmung und jetzt gilt es das Recht für
die ampelparteien dass wir Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen apropo Vertrauen der
Posten für die in Hessen krachend
gescheiterte bundesinnenministerin steht
nicht zur Debatte der Kanzler und die
SPD haben fer ausdrücklich den Rücken
gestärkt ja in Berlin Lehren muss die
Bundesregierung aus diesen Ergebnissen
ziehen besser werden das ist die
einmütige und selbstkritische Ansage der
ampelparteien heute aber wie bei
schlechten Noten in der Schule stellt
sich ja die Frage ob die Parteien
wirklich auch die richtigen Konsequenzen
ziehen und ziehen können denn dafür
müssten sich alle drei ampelparteien
darin einig sein da aber alle drei
Parteien verloren haben werden auch alle
drei ihr jeweiliges Profil scharfen
wollen und daher sieht es gerade nicht
nach Gemeinsamkeit aus die klarsten
Forderungen kommen heute von der FDP es
müsse eine asylwende geben das Thema
haben viele ampelwähler ja nach rechts
getrieben eine härtere Gangart beim
Thema Migration aber dürfte dann für
wichtige Teile der Grünen ein Problem
sein die Spreizung in der Koalition ist
da wie auch bei den Klimabelastung ja
besonders groß vor allem aber für Olaf
Scholz dürfte es künftig unbequemer
werden denn aus der SPD hört man immer
mehr Rufe nach eigener Erkennbarkeit es
reiche einfach nicht mehr aus sich eher
profillos hinter dem Kanzler rück zu
Verhalten der allzu oft als
Schiedsrichter auftretende Kanzler habe
vom Wähler gerade selbst eine gelbe
Karte
bekommen danke für diese Analyse aus
Berlin Theo Kol warad
das ein großer Gewinner dieser
Landtagswahlen ist die AFD mit ihrem
bisher besten Ergebnis in
Westdeutschland allerdings ohne
regierungsoption denn keine der
demokratischen Parteien will mit ihr
zusammenarbeiten die Wahlsieger der
Union sehen sich bestätigt auch in ihrer
Migrationspolitik wenn die Ampel da
Zusammenarbeit wolle müsse sie ihre
Position komplett ändern fordert
parteichf März wi hescher hat mehr bei
der CDU herrscht gute Laune aber keine
Einigkeit über den Kurs was war
wahlentscheidend der Parteivorsitzende
beansprucht einen Teil des Erfolgs für
sich etwa durch seine provokanten
Aussagen über abgelehnte
Asylbewerber ich habe für meine
Zuspitzung die ich gelegentlich dann
auch mal mache in Hessen und in Bayern
sehr sehr sehr viel Zustimmung bekommen
ich denke mal das hat das Wahlergebnis
auch nach oben mitgebracht wir haben uns
nicht verleiten lassen an irgendwelchen
Rändern zu fischen sondern wir haben
eine Politik der Mitte formuliert in
Bayern will Markus Söder mit den Freien
Wählern zusammen weiterreieren die
Tonlage allerdings angespannt ich rate
allen auf dem Teppich zu bleiben keine
Selbstüberschätzung zu betreiben sondern
schon und vernünftig zu sein die
Größenverhältnisse zu realisieren wir
appellieren also an die CSU sehr schnell
jetzt gesprächsbereit zu sein keine
größeren Personal oder sonstigen
strukturdebatten zu führen nicht ewig
Wunden zu lecken zweitstärkste Kraft in
Hessen drittstärkste Kraft in Bayern die
AFD sieht sich nun auch im Westen
angekommen und
regierungsbereit es ist ein ganz klares
Votum für eine Mitte
Rechtsregierung und diese
brandmauerdiskussion das habe ich auch
schon mehrfach gesagt ist zutiefst
undemokratisch weil Millionen von
Wählern ausgeschlossen werden die AFD
hat bei diesen Wahlen vor allem von
frustrierten ampelanhängern
profitiert am Tag nach der Pleite bei
den Wahlen haben mehr als 50 Mitglieder
der Linken den Parteiausschluss von
Sarah Wagenknecht beantragt sie füge der
Linken schweren Schaden zu vor allem
durch ihre Überlegungen zur Gründung
einer neuen Partei heißt es in dem
Antrag zu den Unterzeichnern gehören
Abgeordnete des Bundestags und von
Landtagen außerdem Mitglieder von
Landesvorständen was sind die Ursachen
für die Lohnlücke zwischen Mann und Frau
was behindert weibliche Karrieren dazu
forscht die usökonomin Claudia golden
seit Jahrzehnten und bekommt dafür
dieses Jahr den
Wirtschaftsnobelpreis die 77jährige ist
Professorin an der Harvard Universität
sie ist erst die dritte Frau die den
Wirtschaftsnobelpreis bekommt und die
erste die ihn allein
erhält und jetzt Fußball Männer die
Nationalmannschaft hat sich auf den Weg
in die USA gemacht kein glücklicher
Zeitpunkt für so eine Reise sagen
Kritiker Ort nee klar aber es bleibt
nichts anderes übrig der Bundestrainer
nimmt mit seinen Spielern gemeinsam die
Herausforderung an die lange vor der
Ehre nagelsmann beschlossene
testspielreise soll dazu dienen
verlorenes renomme zurückzugewinnen und
neuen und alten Kandidaten eine Chance
zu geben auch wenn das für die und für
alle anderen zusätzlichen Stress
bedeutet gut aufgelegt präsentiert sich
der neue Bundestrainer vor seiner ersten
Dienstreise bis auf harwarts der wegen
einer ZahnOP nachkommen wird sind alle
Nominierten dabei darunter drei Neulinge
und Rückkehrer Hummels der sich nach
Verletzung fit meldet die Kritik an der
umstrittenen USA Tour von
Vereinstrainern und Spielern wie
Goretzka kann nagelsmann nachvollziehen
aus vereinstrainericht da brauchen man
nicht rumlügen es ist relativ normal
dass man dem kritisch gegenüber steht
würde ich wahrscheinlich genauso sagen
wenn ich noch im Verein wä wir haben
alle eine große Verantwortung die wir
auch spüren besseren Fußball für
Deutschland zu spielen und demnach
sollten wir die Zeit da nutzen und
positiv damit umgehen die Diskussionen
um Sinn und Unsinn der Reise werden das
neue Trainerteam und die 26 Spieler wohl
auch in Amerika
begleiten die fün bayernpis z.B erwartet
nach der Rückkehr in 10 Tagen ein
mammutprrm aber erstmal fliegen sie wohl
gut gelaunt nach Boston dank des
souveränen 3:0 Sieges im Bundesliga
Sonntagsspiel gegen
Freiburg für Thomas duchel war danach
eins der besten bayernpiele seit er da
ist auch weil Kingsley Comand wieder
einmal glänzen konnte mit zwei Treffern
zum 1:0 und hier zum 3:0 kurz vor dem
Ende gegen schwache Freiburger nicht
weniger spiellaunig zeigte sich liru
Sanne vor während und nach seinem
Zusammenspiel mit Harry Kane dass der
deutsche Nationalspieler zum
vorübergehenden 2:0 nutzte danach machte
er sich auf den Weg mit der
Nationalmannschaft in die
USA alle Zusammenfassungen des Spieltags
in der ZDF Mediathek und der heute App
das war's danke schön sonnig und sehr
mild wird es morgen im Südwesten im
Norden wird's kühler und wechselhafter
mehr gleich von Katja horneffer
Christian sieers begrüßt sie im heute
journal um :4 Uhr und hier geht's gleich
weiter mit einem Spezial zur Lage in
nost danke für Ihr Interesse einen
schönen Abend noch und bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend dieses Regenband
trennte die herbstliche Kühle im
Nordosten von sehr viel höheren
Temperaturen im Süden und im Südwesten
Deutschlands da stiegen die Werte am
Nachmittag bis 8 20° im Nordosten waren
es dagegen nur 10 oder 12°. die
Nachttemperaturen zur Zeit sind mild
heute Nacht geht's auf 14 bis 7° runter
und auch heute Nacht fällt noch etwas
Regen zwischen Berlin und dem
Bayerischen Wald Richtung Westen ist es
aufgelockert da bildet sich auch mal
etwas Nebel in Norddeutschland ist es
stärker bewrkt und morgen ziehen die
Regenwolken erstmal ostwärts ab werden
abgelöst von neuem Regen der von der
Nordsee heranzieht aber die Grenze zu
dem freundlicheren Wetter verschiebt
sich immer mehr in den Nordosten uns ist
es morgen im Süden und im Südwesten
strahlend sonnig und zu erwarten uns
auch morgen am oberreim bis zu
28° sonst sind es häufig Werte über 20°
kühler bleibt es hier im Norden und im
Nordosten mit 16 bis 19° und dann kommt
Regen und zwar am Mittwoch der zieht
hier von Norden auf am Donnerstag
erreicht er die Mitte der Freitag wird
in Norddeutschland sogar stürmisch im
Süden bleibt es sonnig und sehr mild mit
bis zu
29° guten Abend